first of all owned it to the pole by  Albania for assistance that's something  that is a display of European solidarity  something that is very important and I  wanted to thank you all for that in  person so that's why we came to say  thank you so I'm eager to feel from you  what is your assessment because damage  assessment is important part it's  Canton  the Evangel  fortunately sometimes the standards have  not been respected and here we are and  as it seems and as I heard it has  structural problems raised yeah it's not  repairable no so it will have to be the  advice of the two team the three teams  that are here is to is better to  demolish and rebuild and to build a new  one and in the same time we have to put  the kids in other yeah and we do it  better and we do it nicer  or buildings that were built by  individuals by not respecting  [Music]